هكذا بات المشهد اليومي في مدن الضفه
الغربيه المحتله بالتزامن مع استمرار
العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال في ساعات
ما بعد منتصف الليل نفذ الاحتلال عمليه
عسكريه في مدينه جنين ومخيمها حيث وصلت
عشرات الاليات العسكريه برفقه الجرافات
الى داخل المخيم واضافه الى المنطقه
الشرقيه من المدينه قام الاحتلال بتدمير
البنى التحتيه من شبكات الصرف الصحي و
شكات المياه وايضا الكهرباء هنا باتت
الصوره اكثر وضوحا بعد انسحاب جيش
الاحتلال من المخيم بشكل كامل وفقا للجنه
المخيم فانها تؤكد تضرر ما يزيد عن 2700
منزل منذ السابع من اكتوبر منها 113 منزلا
بشكل كامل بفعل اعتداءات الاحتلال
المتواصله على المخيم اضافه للطرقات التي
قام الاحتلال بتدميرها بشكل كلي من مخيم
جنين ليث
جعار
الجزيره